gaza en confinement tous les lieux
publics ont été fermés bar restaurant
école tout comme les mosquées
normalement très fréquentée en ce mois
de ramadhan malgré un moral à plat les
gazaouis entend bien perpétuer les
traditions pour entretenir l'atmosphère
si particulière de ce mois sacré c'est
le cas de sa machine qui fait de la
gravure sur bois
malheureusement avec l'arrivée du
coronavirus j'ai dû arrêter mon activité
mais avec les préparatifs du mois saint
j'ai repris le travail pour fabriquer
les traditionnels lanterne du ramadan
pour moi elles sont indissociables de
l'ambiance de l'atmosphère chaleureuse
et des traditions de ce mois sacré ça
nous permet de nous évader un peu et
d'oublier ces temps difficiles lors des
trois mandats pour les palestiniens qui
vont devoir cette année cohabiter avec
le coronavirus des précautions
particulières s'impose si seulement dix
sept cas de contamination ont été
officiellement recensés le blocus
empêche le personnel soignant de
s'équiper efficacement cap avoir comme
mais là en tant que personnel soignant
nous faisons face à de nombreuses
difficultés on enfin les canards oies à
la da'wa notamment à cause du manque de
moyens et d'outils médicaux qui nous
aide à lutter contre ce fléau
à l'époque un art n'a qu'à non fait
nous manquons notamment de masques et de
produits désinfectants
sans parler du manque d'appareils
respiratoires qui nous aident en cas
d'aggravation de la maladie
alois confinement oblige la situation
économique s'est également dégradée dans
une région où 80% de la population
dépend de l'aide alimentaire de l'onu
la bande de gaza traverse une période
difficile après les bombardements que
nous avons connue et le blocus sévère
sous lequel nous vivons nous devons
maintenant faire face à l'arrivée de ce
corps navires us qui a dégradé la
situation économique le commerce est
fortement touchée
la situation s'est vraiment très
dégradée dans la bande de gaza presque
un habitant sur deux est au chômage
une précarité qui rend l'accès aux soins
très difficile pour de nombreux
habitants
si l'épidémie prend de l'ampleur les
autorités craignent qu'elle devienne
incontrôlable le territoire gazaoui ne
compte que 75 lits en réanimation
les médecins espèrent disposer de 100
places dans les prochains jours